please go ahead okay thanks for anything
so I will talk about the sketching
complexity of draft and hypergraph
counting this is Jang joint work with
John Keller and price both the duty asti
okay so this is the problem that we want
to solve we're given a large graph G and
a small query graph H such as the graph
shown on the slide and we want to
compute the number of occurrences of h
ng approximately one fairly standard
example is something of the following
sort perhaps of my setting is the data
graph is say the facebook graph and the
query graph H is a triangle and maybe I
want to compute approximately the number
of triangles on Facebook this is a the
triangle count is a very important
property of social networks so for
instance the clustering coefficient of a
social network is nothing but three
times the triangle count divided by the
number of two hot paths which reflects
the probability of two neighbors to two
friends of a certain person knowing each
other so it's a measure of he's a myself
a network well
triangles are not the only graphs that
we want to count in large data graphs
for instance this is a very nice work of
Gonder and others suggests sub graph
frequencies for some graphs of small
size size about four as a important
signature of a social network and there
is a four note sub graphs play a role
well some granting also has other
applications so in social networks
biological networks and other networks
analysis and that's what we want to
study now in this work we are interested
in understanding the complexity of
approximate sub graph counting on big
graphs and in particular the standard
model to look at is the streaming model
of computation so here edges of our
graph arrive in some arbitrary orders a
stream roughly like this and as the
algorithm is scanning the stream it can
only use a bounded amount of space
bounded by s and at the end of the
passage should output the approximate
count
well this model is known as the
insertion only streaming model because
in this model edges are only inserted
into the graph into this work we're
actually interested in the more general
dynamic streaming model that is here
edges get to be inserted and deleted in
the stream and insertions and deletions
are as long as there is a valid gravity
so how does one how does one solve how
does one design design algorithms for
then I need graphs well really
essentially the only technique that we
know to work very well is the technique
of linear sketching so we think of the
object that is being updated in the
stream as a vector X in some high
dimensional space so maybe for a graph
it's an N squared dimensional that tree
that encodes which edges are in the
graph and then the algorithm is a linear
sketch namely we generate a random
matrix s and then maintain s times X as
the updates to the edges come in the
stream the space complexity of that is
just the number of rows in the matrix s
ok so in this in this work and this
particular question will care about
roster above bounded degree so I'll get
to that and yes
overall the problem will be given a
graph that comes it comes in a stream or
others given a graph that you get to
sketch I would put a 1 plus a plus minus
epsilon approximation to the number of
say triangles in this graph ok so good
to pretty much the only technique for
handling dynamic graphs that we know is
linear sketching and one classical
application is getting good
approximations to let's say the
quadratic or the l2 squared norm of the
vector that's being updated in the
stream but there are exciting
applications to graph problems we know
how to construct sparse as far as
spanners and spanning trees the reason
why linear sketching is so effective and
dynamic streams is of course that it's
very easy to maintain linear sketches
when edges are both inserted and deleted
so negative updates are as easy to
maintain as the process as positive
updates so one aspect of the linear
sketching model that will be very
important for us is the fact that the
smugglers is fairly powerful and in
particular in the sketching model one
can implement various sampling
primitives
you can implement them by using a hash
function together with sparse recovery
so questions like sample and edge in the
graph that is given as a stream of
insertions and deletions can be handled
using linear sketch so dynamic streaming
is essentially equivalent to when you're
sketching so because of that we're
interested in understanding the
sketching complexity of subgraph County
so in the rest of the taka will first
tell you about the problem and some of
the prior results on triangle counting
and graph streams this will naturally
lead us to our main results and then I
will talk about some of the lower bound
ideas because this is really the main
contribution of the paper okay so
suppose that I have a graph given to me
as a stream of edges and I want to count
the number of triangles in this graph
for simplicity think of triangles right
now so what is a very natural approach
one very natural those approaches is to
take a sample of the edge set of the
graph and then find triangles in the in
the sample now one immediately realizes
that the variance of such approaches
could be quite high what if one edge has
a huge impact on the triangle count of
the graph and because of that there has
been a number of works that try to
parameterize the space complexity of the
triangle counting algorithm in terms of
the triangle degrees of edges of
vertices so for instance one assumes
that the triangle degree of the maximum
number of triangles that are given edge
participates in is fairly small and
bounds the efficiency of the algorithm
in terms of this parameter so the paper
of John and Eric from a sort of 17 for
instance give some of the nice bounds on
this vein okay well on the other hand
examples of this form seem a little bit
unnatural because in real graphs are
fairly sparse and it's unlikely that
most of the sub graph counts are
contributed by the single edge or by
single vertex so in this work were
interested in understanding the
sketching complexity of sub graph
counting in bounded degree graphs so
from now on I will assume that my data
graph G in which I want to count sub
graphs has max degree bounded by some D
and I will assume that D is a constant
and in fact everything generalizes to an
arbitrary D there will be some poly D
dependence in the in the bounds which I
will hide for the stock all right
good so just to set the stage let me
consider the following simple setting
suppose that I have a stream of edges
and this is an insertion only stream and
I want to approximate the number of
triangles in the graph that is presented
here is a very nice and simple algorithm
of Johari in got see that aprox
number of triangles in order the number
of edges divided by T space assuming
that the graph is bounded degree now
note that pretty much all of the
triangle counting results have space
complexity of the form some function of
the graph let's say the number of edges
divided by some increasing function of
the number of triangles in the graph now
this is natural because one can show
that if the number of triangles in the
graph is smaller from the order of a
constant then a linear space is needed
to approximate a triangle count in a
bounded degree graph so for us every
vertex has say constant degree so n
times just a max degree D then I guess M
times D right because because as I said
I will fix D to be a constant from now
on just do not have any ok good so from
now on T will be the number of triangles
now of course note that there is a
stream your sketching algorithm doesn't
really know what the number of triangles
is but usually this is easy to get
around if you assume an upper bound on
this number then you can repeatedly
sample and see where your estimates
stabilize okay so here's the estimator
that one uses to get order M by T space
well one selects the uniformly random
edge in the stream and that's T be the
position of the edge of the stream and
the estimator is the number of triangles
that the that the edge participates in
in the remainder of the stream times M
well this makes the estimator unbiased
and some so amount of contemplation
reveals that the variance is roughly M
times T so roughly M which is the the
the the upper bound the max the maximum
of the value that the estimator takes
times the actual expectation and in a
particular order M by T samples suffice
to get a constant factor approximation
also when I talk about approximating
triangle counter will always say that I
want to approximate it to within a
constant factor everything
c'est generalizes to 1 plus epsilon
approximations with appropriate loss in
parameters expectation of the estimator
is T and the variance is empty yes yes
so I need the variance over expectation
squared so M divided by T about my T
samples we'll all right good so but now
one notes that this is really something
that one can only do an insertion only
stream I sample an actual edge that
exists in the graph and then collect all
the all the all the edges that are
incident on the corresponding vertices
in the rest of the graph so what can one
do in the sketching model where it
tricks like that are not available let's
let's consider some simple examples so
the first suggestion is perhaps just
take a sample of the edges edge set of
the graph at some rate P look to the
sample be e prime and then my estimator
is going to be the number of triangles
in the in the sample so rather the
number of triangles and the sample
divided by B cubed which is exactly what
will make the estimator unbiased okay
well how how small can how small can P
be in order to still get a good
approximation to the triangle count
well one realizes that in order to have
good variance it really suffice a
student is this necessary insufficient
to ensure that we capture at least one
triangle or at least a large constant
number of triangles this is because I
made the bounded degree assumption so
that the variance of this estimators is
small so what this means is that this
will work as long as the sampling
probability P is at least T to the minus
one-third because there are T trial
triangles over all every one of them is
captured with probability P cubed and so
this will make ensure that the variance
is small I get it
multiplicative bout what is the space
complexity of that
well I took every edge with probability
P so it's a divided by T to the 1/3 so
that's worse that m bar than M by T that
we had in the insertion only streams and
we would like to improve upon this ok
very nice so let's let's try something
else
it's instead of sampling edges let's try
sampling vertices here's another another
estimator that is a little bit more
interesting
oh we sample every vertex of the graph
in
with probability P and collect the edges
of the induced sub graph so I let a
prime be the edge set of the graph
intersected with V prime times V Prime
so look at the inducer now again my
estimator is the number of triangles
that I find divided by P cubed now for a
slightly different reason every triangle
has 3 vertices so now how large does P
need to be in order for this to converge
to to have good variance well
the calculation is the same because P
over P needs to be at least T to the
minus 1/3 I want to capture at least a
lot of number of triangles but the space
requirement now is much better because I
only keep a given edge with probability
P squared both endpoints have to be in
so this improves the space complexity or
the skill the sketching complexity of
our our algorithm to M divided by T to
the 2/3 and note that Emma's really
order n here because I'm still on making
this bounded degree assumption okay nope
note that these are all sketching
algorithms as I mentioned before
sampling primitives can be implemented
in sketch okay so this is very
encouraging and suggests that we should
work a little bit harder to improve this
further but it turns out that this is
not possible and this brings us to the
main result of the stock missing
something so we said that it was an M
over T okay so there was an over T
algorithm for insertion only streams
right but now I want to understand what
one can do if I only get to access the
graph in the sketching models and in
particular one notes that whatever was
being done in the insertion only stream
doesn't really it's not not easy to
implement
oh good so this brings us to our main
results well first this simple algorithm
that I outlined shows that you can
approximately triangle count in a
bounded degree graph in M over T to the
2/3 space in the sketching model and we
show that this is best possible right ok
yes so that that's so the question was
how does that go together with the
example that I was showing at the
beginning of the talk where I had one
edge that controlled a huge number of
triangles after that I said that if one
edge gets to control with say Omega and
triangles then this will be a not a good
idea but yeah but we're working in the
bounded degree models so we assume for
the graphs our graphs are bounded degree
so one edge can't really control too
many triangles yeah okay
good so this is best possible and with
the natural question at this point is
how exactly did we get the constant of
2/3 namely how does this generalize
beyond triangles so maybe I want to
count occurrences of a four cycle in my
data graph that is bounded degree okay
well show that the right parameter to
look at sort of the right parameter that
governs the sketching complexity of some
rough counting is the fractional vertex
cover of the query graph that we're
trying to count so what is the
fractional vertex cover let me remind
you so suppose that I have my graph H so
let's say a triangle or maybe a star or
a four cycle the fractional vertex cover
is the smallest amount of mass that I
need to put on the vertices of the graph
to ensure that every edge in the query
graph is covered to the extent of at
least one so I'm trying to cover edges
by vertices and I want to minimize the
amount of mass that I put on the
vertices of the graph okay well if my
graph is a triangle then the optimal
vertex cover size is 3 3 by 2 I put half
mass of one half one half one half on
every node in the graph if my graphs
let's say is a four cycle then I can
either
put 1 1 0 0 or 1/2 1/2 1/2 and let's say
if I have a star then the verdicts in
fractional vertex cover size is 1 I just
cover the middle note ok and we show
that this is exactly the parameter that
governs the sketching complexity in the
former case the the sketching complexity
will be M over T to the 2/3 so 2 to the
1 over the vertex cover size and
similarly for the rest so formally for
every graph H we show that there exists
in a sketch with the target dimension M
divided by T to the 1 or fractional
vertex cover size that approximates the
number of occurrences of H to a constant
factor and again all constant factors
can be made 1 plus 1 plus epsilon
approximation ok so let me just say a
couple of words about the estimator the
estimator works roughly as follows one
first color is the data graph and and
the query graph and using colors 1
through the number of vertices in the
query graph so we just randomly assign
random we give names to a vertices of
both graphs and then we do vertex
something on the graph G but it's not
verdict sampling at the same rate but
rather now every vertex of the graph G
has an Associated vertex of the graph H
so we look at the amount of mass that
the optimal fractional vertex cover
assigns to that particular node and we
sample a vertex of G with probability
which is some parameter P which is the
space by M raised to power that that
amount and then this gives us a random
random vertex induced subgraph we count
the number of colored copies of a ship
that's out graph one can check that
indeed the how does the vertex
fractional vertex cover come into play
here for instance one can check that the
space complexity is indeed at most s why
because for every edge in the graph G
the probability of keeping an edge is
the sampling parameter raised to power
which is the amount of mass that was
placed on one node plus the amount of
mass on the other node and this is at
least one so the probability of sampling
any given edge of G will be at most
we'll be at most the correct space good
and some further contemplation reveals
that the probability of keeping a copy
of H is related to the actual verdicts
cover size because we just have to keep
every single vertex and you get a
product over over issues of that copy
and that's exactly okay good so this is
the upper bound and what we show is that
this is basically typed for any graph
for every graph H with fractional vertex
cover every algorithm must use at least
so I think there's a paper free good and
con I think that bounds the that answers
the following question suppose that I
have a graph G with M edges and I have a
sub graph H how many occurrences of H
can I have ng and the answer is M raised
to the fractional edge cover number of H
so this is the there is a difference
we're using vertex covers and the reason
is that our graph G is a bounded degree
graph and if you don't have that
assumption then the the edge covers seem
to be more relevant for these questions
this is also related to some work in the
database community again on instance
optimal database joins something else
also known as the AGM bar AGM bound
which should bounce the size of the on a
given database okay good so these are
the results for graphs we prove similar
results for hyper graph although for
these results there's some loss in
particular the upper bound is exactly
the same but the lower bound has an
extra factor of two in the exponent here
so these are not quite tight okay good
so in the remaining time let me say a
few words about the how we prove the
lower bound and we want to prove that
action vertex cover is indeed the right
parameter we use if we start with the
standard observation that any sketching
algorithm heald's a simultaneous
communication product and for instance
let me outline the proof techniques for
for trial triangle counting so since
we're doing triangle counting then our
proof will go through a three player
communication game that we define there
are three players Alice Bob and Charlie
that controls the three edges of the
triangle and they will communicate
simultaneously with the referee we will
use free analytic techniques inspired by
the boolean hidden matching style
analysis of girls key and others and
some of the recent results along along
these lines so interesting we will
design some new techniques for analyzing
multiplayer games through free analysis
and for analyzing promised versions of
related problems so here's the
communication game there are three
players Alice Bob and Charlie those are
here they are and all of them are given
edges of a graph so we have a tripartite
graph which is a union of three
matchings ma MB and MC so the red green
and these matchings are matchings are
essentially permutations of there are
three n vertices and the matchings are
basically permutations on veut on sets
of n vertices these mashings will be
selected uniformly at random subject to
the product of these three permutations
being the identity this is the same as
saying that our tripartite graph is a
union of triangles now besides the edges
of the matchings our players get bit on
the edges of the matching bits of length
n so there is X a xB and X C and the
game with row ability half isn't the yes
case with probability half is in the no
case in the yes case the bits that the
players observe on the edges of the
matching here they are XOR to 0
simultaneously for all triangles in the
game in the no case they XOR to 1
um so let me just illustrate citizens so
the graph is indeed a union of triangles
and this game is in the es case or the
bits and all triangles XOR to zero so
Alice Bob and Charlie look at their
input and simultaneously send a message
to a referee the referee should guess
which of the two states the game wasn't
oh and the matchings are random so this
is rather loose okay so now what is the
relation to triangle counting here is
the reduction suppose that L is Bob and
Charlie have a sketching algorithm for
triangle counting then what they do is
as soon as they receive their matchings
they look at the edges that have zeros
written on them and sketch these edges
and send the sketch to the referee the
referee combines the sketches and checks
whether or not the Cris funding graph
had a large number of triangles and if
we were in the yes case then we'll get
about n by four triangles why because in
the yes case over every triangle the
bits were random subject to exploring to
zero so a probability quarter will
actually see zero zero zero so the
corresponding graph will be a union of
triangles and single edges with
remaining okay good so we have a lot of
a linear number of triangles in the S
case in the no case there are no
triangles because the bits exhort to one
so if we keep the zero edges we will not
have a single child we prove that at
least n to the one third communication
is required from Alice Bob and Charlie
to the referee to get a constant
advantage over random guessing why is
this good well note that in this
particular case the number of triangles
in the yes case is omega and so what our
lower bound is supposed to our algorithm
would require n over T to the 2/3 so n
divided by n to the 2/3 and to the 1/3
space and the lower bound matches
exactly that of when T is smaller there
is a tweak of the game that handles the
situation
okay so let me just quickly sketch how
the analysis goes well first it is
useful to see what the players would do
if they were constrained to using very
simple product goals the protocol is
this as soon as Alice Bob and Charlie
look at their matchings they decide on
some edges on which they will want to
keep the bit there they will they will
cost somewhere they will send some of
the bits to the referee and they will
forget all the other bits so suppose
that they choose that each of them
chooses subset s of edges based on the
matching that they see and they send the
bits on these edges to the referee so
one example protocol is maybe Alice
Lukas looks at her matching as a checks
is it true then it just conveys all the
bits and all the edges with both end
points having indices smaller than n to
the 2/3 let's see and then if the
referee has a triangle that it received
Oh a triangle such that it received all
bits on the corresponding edges then the
referee can decide which of the two
cases this game was in so the question
is how large should the set s be well
let me sketch the argument one can think
about this as follows
so the challenge is the fact that the
players can coordinate because they
receive edges of the mashings I'm a and
B and MC and these mashings are
dependent
they're only pairwise independent indeed
this is why the interesting verdicts
based sampling protocols exist so one
way of looking at this is to define the
following quantities for every vertex J
let's say on this side of the tripartite
graph we let WM a of J be the indicator
that Alice of L is keeping the
corresponding edge and we define
corresponding indicators for every for
every one of the players and then the
total communication of the players is
the sum of the of the is the expectation
over the sound of the sum of all the
vertices and the parts of the graph of
these indicators good one can check
after a certain amount of contemplation
that the expected number of triangles in
the referee's set is upper bounded by
the following quantity one needs to sum
over all J
the minimum of the essentially the
probability that alice remembers the red
edge going out of J times the
probability that Charlie remembers the
blue edge going out of J times the
probability that the remaining player
remembers this remembers the third edge
and I will just give the intuition here
though the challenge in analyzing this
is exactly the fact that the three
Manning's are only pairwise independent
so this is why we can understand the
probability of both Alice keeping the
red edge and Charlie keeping the blue
one and we have to separate out the
third player okay so it turns out that
the number the expected number of
triangles in the referee set as we show
is bounded by the square root of s cubed
which is the space bar budget divided by
N and that's why the breaking point is s
equals n to the one third and this means
that n to the one third lower bound
holds for sampling protocols okay well
how does one use this intuition to
reason about general protocols well now
suppose that suppose that Alice Bob and
Charlie generic messages to to the
referee so these generic messages from
Alice Bob and Charlie to the referee but
can be viewed as follows we had the bits
on the edges let's call the
concatenation of the bits X and Alice's
message to the referee constraints the
makes the posterior distribution of X
would be uniform over a corresponding
message
Bob's disturbs message corresponds to
again some subset of the boolean cube of
dimension 3n and Charlie's message does
the exact same thing now one crucial
difference here is that whereas in Prior
analysis for analytic analysis one
usually thinks of the uniform prior on
the boolean hypercube here we started
out with a promise that is that the bits
exhort either to zero simultaneously
over all triangles or to one single
teeny ously over all triangles so all in
all one needs to understand the
distribution of these random bits
conditioned on the messages from the
referee this distribution is the product
of three indicator functions
corresponding to the messages from Alice
Bob and Charlie times the indicator of
the times the
prior okay well again some amount of
contemplation and we show that the
posterior distribution of the referee
given the three messages on whether or
not the game was in the yes case or in
the no case can be expressed
conveniently in terms of the Fourier
coefficients of the product of F a FB
and FC now in particular it turns out
that what one needs to do is sum up
these Fourier coefficients over all the
sets of overall this odd collections of
triangles and escape this should be
there should be a triangle here like
this good so this is where the Fourier
analysis comes in so it turns out that
one needs to understand the sum of
Fourier coefficients over triangles of a
product of a B and C how does one do
that well this is where the convolution
theorem and Fourier analysis comes in we
note that by the way here it is more
convenient to work with a certain
normalized Fourier coefficient where
basically the usual Fourier coefficient
is defined as follows we take the
expectation over X in the unit and in
the the cube in the whole binary cube of
minus 1 to the X dot the parity that
we're interested in times the indicator
of the set of the set F the normalized
Fourier coefficient just does the
correct normalization so by the
convolution theorem the Fourier
transform of a product of three
functions is the convolution of the
corresponding Fourier transforms and
this reduces our problem to
understanding a certain convolution
which in this case luckily it turns out
to also be a product because of the
structure of the game and this is where
hyper-connectivity comes in similarly to
fully analytic analysis of the boolean
hidden matching problem and related
streaming questions we start by noticing
that the the sets F a FB and FC they
correspond to typical messages of Alice
Bob and Charlie and because if Alice Tim
Bob and Charlie communicated most s bits
then these are the normalized through
coefficients of the typical
Edge's satisfy certain l2 squared bounds
in Korea domain so this is a consequence
of hyper contractivity so for example
one specific setting says that if I sum
up the three of the squares of
normalized Fourier coefficients over
level one Fourier coefficients that a
single bit then I get at most the amount
of communication that Alice Bob and
Charlie could use and that's very nice
because this lets us essentially massage
the question of analyzing general
protocols into a form that we already
have done so I already showed you rather
gave an outline of how one shows that a
sampling protocol cannot solve the
problem with a less than n to the one
third communication and in the sampling
protocol basically Alice Bob and Charlie
had the task of allocating zero one
weight to the edges on the matchings
that can be basically said do I convey
all the information about the
corresponding bit or do I convey none of
it
so this consequence of hyper
contractivity in the form of l2 squared
bounds in the Fourier coefficients it
shows that essentially we just have to
solve a related problem where L is Bob
and Charlie now get to allocate
fractional weights to the edges of the
graph and the only difference is that
the weights also happen to be l2 squared
constraint but for triangles the
solution of this problem turns out to be
exactly the same as under the l1
constrained version and I think I'm out
of time so let me just say that
hyper-connectivity
lets us argue that a generic Prodigal
can be viewed as a sampling protocol
except that Alice Bob and Charlie don't
just allocate weights to edges but they
also have to allocate weights to
collections of edges and the weights are
bounded and l2 squared sends a very
similar counting argument is the one
that I showed before shows that even
under l2 constraints for triangles the
optimal solution is that most the bound
on the expected number of triangles that
you catch you which translates into the
posterior probability of the referee is
it most
roughly s cubed over N and this gives us
the result so just a quick summary
what we what we showed is optimal bounds
on the sketching complexity of sub graph
counting and the bounds are tight for
all graphs but they're not quite tight
for hyper graphs and the reason why
they're not tight is that this
equivalence between the problem under l2
constraints and the problem under a1
constraints does not quite work for a
hyper or for hyper graphs and we will
lose something there and so that would
be very nice to understand and in
general would be very nice to get other
for an analytical bounds for more
streaming questions right so well lower
bounds are for constant D right but
upper bounds you can you can probably
you can prove a variance bound in terms
of the D and we lose some kind of poly
factor there I think it's inconvenient
so they might be non-constant but you
could still have a bounder how many
triangles and HP it's right in that case
you're you could do the analysis in
terms of that parameter right well one
kid one could do a variance but yes in
terms of that
Big Mike
[Applause]